Secretary of State Mike Pompeo says the
Trump administration will not tolerate
Russian interference in this fall's
elections Pompeyo made the promise to a
congressional hearing today he did not
say what the president might do about it
his testimony was interrupted briefly
today over a totally unrelated matter of
course by Richardson has the story from
the State Department tonight Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo was there to answer
questions about the State Department's
budget but this hearing got testy over
another issue his questioning of Hillary
Clinton during a 2015 Benghazi hearing
when he was still a member of Congress I
take the matter securedoc very serious
never make an accusation real if I could
just explain okay time but we want to
give the secretary chance to respond let
me tell you that testifying before the
House Foreign Affairs Committee
secretary Pompeo also addressed how the
Venezuelan government notified the State
Department this morning that it is
injecting two American diplomats that's
in response to US sanctions on Venezuela
after its president Nicolas Maduro won
re-election the u.s. considers that
election a sham on Russia
Pompeyo contends the Trump
administration has aggressively punished
its behavior though acknowledges
officials must do more we have not been
able to achieve deterrence effective
deterrence of some of these efforts of
the Russians but this administration has
taken enormous efforts to push back
against Russia that haven't been done in
an awfully long time
he says the administration will
implement quote appropriate
countermeasures against Russian
interference after the more than three
our hearing Pompeo hosted officials from
Japan Germany and China
Pompeyo says the State Department is
sending a medical team to Guangzhou
China after a u.s. employee reported
symptoms that are very similar to those
two dozen American diplomats in Cuba
experienced we've notified China of what
took place as best we know it and they
have responded in a way that it is
exactly the right worse
Pompeyo also discussed with China's
foreign minister the upcoming summit
between president Trump and kim
jeong-hoon he says officials here at the
State Department are still planning and
driving for a June 12th meeting he also
notes the United States will not give
any concessions to North Korea until it
has credible information credible
demonstration that its dismantling its
nuclear program right
and speaking of concessions rich Iran is
now making demands of Europe on this
nuclear deal it is just posted a short
while ago the European countries and
those remaining in the Iran nuclear deal
are negotiating with Iran trying to keep
it in the Iran nuclear agreement to
salvage the deal well now Iran has just
posted a list of demands of the European
allies Britain Germany and France the
Ayatollah Khomeini wants them to fully
guarantee Iranian oil sales safeguard
Iran's trade against US sanctions and
leave its ballistic missile program and
regional policies alone the ayatollah
says that's the price for keeping Iran
in the nuclear deal Iran is now putting
the Europeans between the United States
and Iran
that's because Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo announced Monday 12 demands of
Iran saying it's going to put the
strongest sanctions in history against
it if it doesn't comply with those US
demands right check it out Rick
Richardson at the State Department rich
thank you